there's a new
article in forbes that says survey
reveals 80 percent of workers
would quit their job for this one thing
80 of workers would consider quitting
their current position for a job that
focused
more on employees mental health
if my boss says some of these folks
would just ask me how i'm doing would
they give me permission to log off at
night because now that we're working at
home we don't have these natural
these natural separation moments right
um now that folks have been worried for
six months we ran on adrenaline right
for a long time
now that folks are still worried am i
gonna have a job am i not
people are hiring again is it slowing
down it's getting faster we've got this
i don't know if you've heard um
this is kind of an underground thing but
we have this uh presidential election
coming that's added some stress to
people's lives just a little bit
and so folks are they're they're
realizing hey
this is not going to be a two-week wait
till the the curve flattens this is
going to
be the for the foreseeable future right
and it's getting harder
and harder and harder just to deal with
it and so
um i want to encourage supervisors
bosses
this is an off this this is a touchy
feely thing right caring about your
employees but it's bigger than that this
has an roi to it
if you take care of folks at home if you
check in with them see how they're doing
if you make sure you're encouraging them
to take time off if you go in at five
o'clock
six o'clock and see who's still logged
in and you text them and say hey get off
for today
go for a walk go enjoy some stuff get
out of here and encourage your folks to
take care of themselves
they're going to want to stick around
longer they're going to be more
productive in the long run
and really they're going to um they're
going to have lower anxiety lower stress
in their daily lives it's gonna make
them
make them better employees yeah well i
think as leaders you know we are about
to
embark on one of our largest leadership
conferences entre leadership master
series
uh where we are growing business owners
and leaders all across the country
but it is imperative for leaders to
check in on their people
and that means you know we've got
technology at our fingertips for the
sake of business
you have it at the at your fingertips
for the sake of your team
and that means even if you facetime
skype look at your people
see in their eyes i've had so many
people tell me i'm doing fine or i'm
doing okay
and their eyes tell me something
different and i know as a leader i need
to follow back up with so-and-so
or see really see what's happening and
so i want you to care enough to show up
and to and to care about your team uh we
we've got to get
through this and the best way to do it
is sticking together here's something
that i want every leader to hear
every business owner every middle
manager upper management
lower management i took a call from a
woman the other day asking
she was struggling with her
five-year-old during this transition and
she said i used to have a happy-go-lucky
five-year-old
and now she's not she's dealt with the
stress of me and my husband
has been a hard six months how do i help
her get back to be the
happy-go-lucky kid she was and i told
her because you're not gonna like this
but that season's over we have we have
an after now
there was a before when everyone was
running around and we were chasing busy
and more
right and we could really squash our
employees and and get blood out of that
turnip
we're we're in a different world now and
so it's going to require different
leadership
it's going to require people who lean in
even if it's uncomfortable if you don't
know how
ask your employees how they're doing
encourage them to take care of
themselves
let's let an evening go by where folks
can get some sleep or they log off and
you're going to get the hours back the
next day or the next day
right but be proactive about taking care
of your people it will help your
business in the long run it will help
you in the long run
but it it's the right thing to do that's
the right thing to do chris no you're
absolutely right
new leadership for new times well people
often ask me about return
on investment roi um i'll take it a step
further i think there's a return on
involvement for leaders
i think there's a return on inclusion
meaning including people finding out
what's happening in their lives and
and connection and so it is a soft skill
it is a thing that people think there's
well you know that's going to take time
it sure is but listen do you want to
care about the people that you have on
your team
or do you want to train some new ones i
mean that's really what it boils down to
and so when you care enough to getting
connected you're actually invested in
their lives
and you want to check on them and so be
intentional that's that's shocking to me
it is 80 80 would quit their jobs
uh for for something that focus a little
bit more on mental health now i want to
flip it on them
okay you've got a responsibility to take
care of yourself workers across the
country ah
not waiting on you've got to log off
you've got to have boundaries even if
you're stuck at home
right make sure you're going for walks
make sure you're connecting with people
and you make sure you define your work
day the best that you can
it's easy to just sit at the sit on the
couch at six o'clock seven o'clock eight
o'clock eat on the couch
keep working into nine ten eleven
o'clock you're gonna make yourself
nuts you're gonna slowly grind yourself
down to a nub you've got a
responsibility to own your mental health
too
it's easy to blame our bosses and there
are bosses across the country that
deserve blame
but we have to take care of our mental
health too no i agree with you
and so if you're out there and this has
struck a nerve and you start to go man
i'm in leadership and i need help or i
want to make sure i'm
starting to do these things better go
over to entreleadership.com
entree leadership is the brand and kind
of the process of how this company
has grown from a card table in dave's
living room uh now to
over a thousand team members and so
again
entreleadership.com where you can begin
to learn more
about leadership more about being a
business owner uh
get connected and learning more about
not doing leadership alone
leadership can be a very lonely thing if
you're not connected you don't have
other like-minded people
remember as john maxwell calls it the
leadership lid we we have to be
open to new information so we can get
poured into
so now we have the ability to be able to
pour into other people
and that's part of that growing and
mentoring and coaching people
as we grow so again go over to
entreleadership.com
as i said we've got our big event
happening entre
leadership master series uh that is
going to be kicking off next week and
dave and myself and you and ken coleman
will be
training and teaching leaders and it is
a blast
um as i tell people it's like getting a
master's or a phd in leadership
and it's stuff that you can really apply
not just theory
this is stuff that really impacts
people's lives as well as their
businesses